ladies and gentlemen it's a great
pleasure to welcome so many people here
today
ocean democracy today in the u.s.a on
the fourth of march eight ER one at was
President Thomas Jefferson who in his
first inaugural address express his
conviction that America is quote unquote
the world's best hope and in 1862 it was
President Lincoln who reminded Congress
that America is again quote unquote the
last best hope of Earth just two decades
later the millions and millions who
emigrated to America they all would pass
the Statue of Liberty if on its pedestal
the immortal words of emma lazarus a
mighty woman with a torch whose flame is
the imprisoned lightning and her name
morrow of exiles keep ancient lands your
storied pomp she cries with silent lips
give me your tired your poor send these
the homeless tempest-tossed to me i lift
my lamp beside the Golden Door now
welcomed by these words on the Statue of
Liberty for all those millions just like
Leveson and unlink all-america
represented the last best hope of Earth
why because America is a democracy and
this word became a Shibboleth for a
whole idea of civilization democracy
meant for all of them Liberty equal
rights the rule of law separation of
powers freedom of expression freedom of
religion a world of reason the pursuit
of happiness when in the 20th century
the old world our Ward's came in the
grip of a self-inflicted totalitarianism
as we should never forget that Mussolini
Hitler Lenin and Stalin will all
welcomed by millions for other millions
in particular Jews anti-fascist artists
intellectuals America again proved to be
the last best hope of Earth one of those
who found refugees in America
what's the North lyst a Nobel Prize
winner Thomas one who not long after his
arrival in 1938 went on a coast-to-coast
town hall lecture series on entitled the
common the coming victory of democracy
now here is what mom says at the end of
this lecture in 1938 I quote for years
ago I visited America for the first time
and since then I've come here each year
I was delighted with the atmosphere that
I found here because it was almost free
of the poison that fill the air of
Europe because here in contrast to the
cultural fatigue and inclination to
barbarism in the old world there exists
a youthful respectful culture a youthful
sensitivity to its values and its
products I believe that for the duration
of the present European Dark Age the
center of Western civilization will
shift to America America has received
much from Europe and that depth will be
amply replayed if by saving our
traditional values from the present
gloom she can preserve for them a
brighter future that will once again
find europe and america united in the
great tasks of humanity after the second
world war with America as superpower
democracy and America became synonyms
synonyms for the free and civilized
world and that part of the world where
there is no democracy well there is no
freedom that's not civilized and
therefore the whole world should be made
safe or and through democracy ladies and
gentlemen the Nexus Institute has chosen
to organize to a symposium democracy
today in the USA as we are convinced
that Alexis de Tocqueville's what the
electric field said in this magnificent
book democracy in America is still very
true to have an understanding of
Americans democracy will help us
Europeans to understand what we have to
hope for
or fear from and when American democracy
is in trouble then that will affect
something much larger than the world as
it is nowadays because it will have a
tremendous effect on our worldview it
does affect our notion or the civilized
world is supposed to be okay I'm very
pleased that an all-star American team
accepted my invitation to come to
Amsterdam to engage in a conversation
about issues and questions which will
not only determine the future of America
but will have a huge impact on European
society as well so please join me in
very warm welcome to Anne Applebaum sean
wilentz
right your bag of each
ambassador Derek's hero and Randall
Kennedy
now unfortunately and very much to our
regret due to family circumstances um I
would dear friend as an efficient could
not make it but Jeb Bush is here and we
are very proud of having him and honor
that he has chosen the Nexus symposium
to present his views and discuss with
our other guests democracy today in the
USA so ladies and gentlemen a heartfelt
welcome to Governor Jeb Bush good
afternoon it is a joy to be here I've
heard so much about the nexus institute
and the thoughtful conversation we're
going to have for the next three hours
and the fact that you all are here to
hear about something that is very
important time with five incredible
scholars and a former politician
hopefully we'll all learn together about
the challenges of democracy in our
country and the impact that might have
here in Europe as well we share a common
culture we share a lot and I think our
political systems also are being
impacted in similar ways in retrospect I
was a candidate you may know I didn't
wasn't there long enough you might not
have noticed the the campaign but it's
it was actually 13 14 months and during
that time I learned a lot I did share I
listened to the frustrations of a lot of
people that were concerned that our
system wasn't working that our democracy
really wasn't working our government
wasn't working in our country a country
where Europeans not that long ago would
would constantly say you Yanks our way
overly optimistic about things naively
optimistic no won't no one can say that
anymore about America for the last
literally for the last decade Americans
when
in polls will say that we're on the
wrong track and they're deeply
pessimistic about the future for the
first time in American history people
believe their children will have less
opportunities and what they had and in
that environment it was it's not
surprising to see the disruption of the
political system in fact I would argue
and that's the point of my brief remarks
here today that this has all been
happening perhaps in increments not
discernable to the naked eye for an
extended period of time the financial
crisis makes all of this kind of cascade
out into the public domain and the
changing culture and many other things
now has changed our political system and
I wanted to give you my views about why
this is because there are some rational
things that have been taken place where
we haven't made adjustments first we are
living through one of the most
extraordinary times in world history
where the advancement of technology and
innovation is extraordinary I mean we're
moving at warp speed with the changes
that are taking place in the
institutions that we've relied on to
allow to provide some security and
stability in our lives have stopped to
work to the degree that they used to
work now technology and advancement an
innovation is phenomenal if you're
educated if you're motivated if you have
a support mechanism around you you can
embrace that technology and live a life
of purpose and meaning that that is
awe-inspiring in fact I would say is
probably the best time to be alive
babies brought into the world today that
have loving families that that have
resources will live easily till they're
120 130 years old they'll live healthier
I'm not sure exactly what the world
looks like a hundred years from now but
it is because of technology and
innovation that you can dream the
biggest possible dreams on the other
side of this though technology has
created massive disruption think about
facebook facebook has a market
capitalization of value that is on a net
present value basis I think greater than
General Motors at the height of its
power General Motors at the height of
its power had 300,000 employees facebook
I think probably has 4,000 employees you
see the aggregation
accumulation of wealth in ways that no
one could have imagined and the the
innovation that's taking place isn't
kind of creating the jobs that we would
expect in in in in the world that we've
that we've gotten accustomed to so
innovation can be your friend but it
also can be a disrupter and there's a
lot of disruption going on in America
today last year Mackenzie did a study
that showed that half of the jobs in the
United States could be disrupted because
of automation babies brought into the
world today perhaps an Amsterdam but
certainly in the United States if you're
if you're born into poverty the
possibility is that you'll never have a
job so imagine if you're a voter and
you're looking at all this disruption
you see your life change and you don't
see the systems that we're there to take
that you know provide security and an
opportunity for you they don't they
don't sense that you don't sense that
their work and you have a financial
crisis it's not a surprise that we have
what is clearly a pretty wild and crazy
political system that's that's because
of that the second issue that I think is
a trend that's been taking place for
more than a generation is globalization
again globalization has brought huge
benefits to the United States in terms
of lower consumer prices new markets
people being lifted out of poverty that
creates great potential for our country
but globalization also means when you
lag behind when you don't modernize your
regulatory system when your education
system operates as though it was in
nineteen fifty where higher education
operates with the same model that
applied a hundred years ago and you see
the challenges that take place you don't
have the benefit in an a in a globalized
world where money can is fungible where
you'll see investment patterns move to
what the best climate is we lose our
competitive edge and it creates greater
imperils more and more people and so
again once again a trend that is a
secular trend that has nothing to do
with American politics has created
strains on our democracy that that the
political system hasn't hasn't dealt
with the third
secular trend that is pretty dramatic
and it's certainly dramatic in Europe
and equally dramatic in the United
States is that our demographics have
changed dramatically my plan by the way
for everybody in this room 10 years from
now is that you're going to be 10 years
older anybody argue with that well the
simple fact is we're getting older
together and that dramatically changes a
lot the social contract that existed in
Europe certainly and again in the United
States is being torn apart by changing
demographic changes are our demographic
pyramid is inverted and the political
system seems unable or incapable to be
able to confront that great challenge
and people are scared about their future
recently there was a poll done by money
magazine that suggests that sixty-three
percent of Americans cannot afford a
five-hundred-dollar car repair seventy
percent of Americans cannot have a
crisis with it would cost a thousand
dollars or more they don't have liquid
assets to be able to deal with a crisis
if you don't think that impacts the
political system where the anxiety that
people feel about their future where one
car wreck or 111 visit to the emergency
room will change your life and change
your family's life trust me it does and
so in that in that period at this time
of deep anxiety partially related to the
fact of our inability to change the
social contract to deal with the reality
of our changing demographics your people
are fearful I'm the chairman of a
foundation for education reform k-12
education reform in the United States
and hopefully we'll talk about that
today is one of the means by which we we
change we get back in the game as it
relates to making our democracy vibrant
but we created a dependency ratio if you
take people under the age of 18 and you
add up the people over the age of 65 and
you divide it to the rest of the people
that's the dependency ratio and that
dependency ratio in 2010 was 59 by 2030
that'll be 79
in Florida in Arizona Nevada three of
the fastest growing states in the United
States that number will be 90 and in
Florida which had the oldest dependency
ratio and the highest dependency ratio
in 2010 by 2030 every state in the
country will have a higher dependency
ratio than than Florida's of 2010 the
world is changing and yet our political
system and our governance model it seems
ill-equipped to be able to deal with it
in fact I would argue immigration should
be a solution to some of the challenges
that we face when in fact it's now a
political wedge issue that it's like
it's like never ends it's just every
cycle both sides use it as a wedge issue
to garner political votes rather than
taking advantage of this extraordinary
American experience of immigration it
now is is stuck in a groundhogs day it
just never goes away and we're not
taking advantage of the potential to
solve these problems the fourth big
secular change it's taking place in our
countries our culture is changing my
party talks with great uh you know with
speaks a lot about Ronald Reagan well he
was a great president I loved Ronald
Reagan and my dad got to serve eight
years as his vice president and he
changed the world in many ways but that
was a long time ago and our culture is
dramatically different today and the the
the need to be able to update ones
message to talk about the challenges
that we face today seems it seems hard
to do and one of the reasons why we're
in the mess we're in as our culture has
changed today in the United States
forty-two percent of the babies brought
in the world will have a dad obviously
but that dad won't be the husband of mom
and a quarter of all children will grow
up not knowing who their father is this
is an experiment that has never taken
place in in modern history and the
strains that this is now placing on our
system is dramatic and yet and that's a
cultural change that hasn't hasn't been
dealt with in my in my mind we have
social and economic mobility now that
his stall
doubt America was always proud of the
fact that didn't matter where you
started in life if you worked hard and
played by the rules you could be born in
poverty and achieve great things well
today if you're born poor you're more
likely to stay poor than any time in
modern history and if you're born
wealthy you're hanging out with people
of wealth you're living in the zip codes
where wealthy people hang out you go to
the best schools and you're going to
live a life of extraordinary purpose and
meaning and that lack of mobility is one
of the reasons why we have a strain in
our democracy and the inability to deal
with these great challenges I think
makes it easy and easier in retrospect
to see on the left a candidate like
Bernie Sanders and certainly in my party
the emergence of Donald Trump becomes
becomes easier perhaps to understand so
what should we do first and foremost I
hope we get to the point where as
Americans whether you're a liberal or a
conservative or libertarian or a
socialist now I guess we have that you
believe that high sustained economic
growth has to be part of the answer
we're accepting the new normal this
terminology that I find repugnant of two
percent growth one and a half percent
growth one and a half percent or two
percent growth will create demands on
government that will overwhelm us will
make it harder for people to be
optimistic about the future where people
more and more people will will be given
the false choice of what they perceive
to be economic security rather than
Economic Opportunity and the dynamism of
our country will continue to decline at
a time when we need to be significantly
more dynamic higher income by itself
higher growth is by itself won't isn't
the all the answer but without it it
creates very limited possibilities and
we could we could grow be given the
nature of our country given the size its
scale the fact that we have the
potential inside of us we're still
dynamic in many ways we could grow at
two percent more to put it in
perspective two percent growth
compounded out for ten years would
create a Germany of additional economic
activity something like four trillion
dollars of additional economic activity
in the tenth year alone it would create
rising income instead
declining income and my guess is that it
would dramatically change how we go
about viewing our politics if people are
more hopeful and optimistic they won't
fall prey to the false promise they
won't fall prey to the large you know
the the big horse in the room that is
offering all sorts of promises that that
aren't backed by substance and so
economic growth has to be part of this
the second thing that I think is
essential and again I don't believe this
is necessarily a partisan issue as well
or what are the tools that people need
to be able to rise up again how do we
deal with this great challenge of people
feeling like their lives have been
stalled out I don't think the issue is
when we'll talk about this income
inequality I think the issue is the lack
of social and economic mobility and
there are certain things that really
matter as it relates to the chance for
people to rise up the most important one
of which is to move our k12 or K forever
education system make it lifelong and
move it to the 21st century transform
our education system so that more and
more people have the power of knowledge
the tools that come from a quality
education will allow people to be on the
good side of innovation and change
rather than be in overwhelmed by it in
terms of the disruption that it brings
and we've got a long way to go starting
with pre-k all the way through our
higher education system it has not been
challenged to the degree it has to I can
envision an education system 20 years
from now where every child has the
ability to reach their god-given ability
where they gain the skills necessary to
be to be effective in life and where
they can always go back to to adjust
their education based on the
circumstances in which they're living
where everybody learns in their own way
at their own pace rather than to having
little butts in a seat when you're young
be funded by 180 days of breathing
basically where instead of that you have
an education system where you maximize
people's ability to learn and where
people that don't young people that can
learn faster will graduate quicker with
the skills necessary to go get a
post-secondary degree and for those that
are struggling
they get the help necessary to achieve
their objective without being cast
behind today in America this is hard for
people to imagine at least in our
country about a third of our children
graduate from high school career or
college ready we have an 80% high school
graduation rate and everybody applauds
it when it goes up a percentage point
each year something like that but half
of those half of those kids have to take
remedial work again they go to the
Community College take high school
reading in high school math again and if
you want to measure career readiness
we've got a long way to go to match the
European example of having young people
that don't necessarily go to
universities or community colleges to be
able to apply whatever they've learned
to be able to get a meaningful job I
think we need a revolution in education
first and foremost and I think our
political system will be far better off
if we had people that were had the
capacity to achieve earned success it
changes your dynamic if you're
optimistic about the future because you
believe in your own skills and now sadly
more and more people don't believe that
the system works for them the final
thing I'd suggest is that we need to
make government work and that's not a
partisan issue as well I mean if you
believe in larger government you want it
to work if you believe in smaller
government like I do you wanted to work
we have a Veterans Administration for
example that has three hundred sixty
thousand employees it's a lot of people
they've had increases in their budget
that have been in the tens of billions
of dollars over the last decade of time
yet if you look at how ineffective they
are for doing what i would consider
perhaps the highest priority one of the
highest priorities of government which
is to take care of people that have kept
our country safe no one could argue that
they're doing their job right last year
the Veterans Administration to put it
put a specific to the to the challenge
that we face gave out bonuses of 140
million dollars and in that bonus
structure they gave bonuses to managers
of the inside the Veterans
Administration the largest healthcare
system in the world they gave out
bonuses for people getting off waiting
lists for veterans that weren't getting
care well here's the problem
they were getting off the waiting list
people were getting off the waiting list
but not receiving the care and veterans
died and bonuses went out and after the
scan only three people have been fired
now whether you're a liberal or a
conservative that's outrageous that's
shameful and we need to change how
government works if our democracies to
work it seems to me our government needs
to be much more servant oriented if you
will and much more effective and I think
they're tools that we have in place
today to bring our government into the
21st century and there are many examples
of success stories in that regard the
final thing I'll say is a point that I
hope we talk about a little bit which is
in the United States people look at the
political system and they they think of
it as a foreign object they really do I
mean they talk about politics and
government as though it's something
removed from their lives and that makes
it harder to change our political system
and to restore our democracy if people
are disengaged from it in fact politics
is a mirror image of us just as it is
here in the Netherlands it's certainly
that way in the United States it is it
is a circus mirror if you will of our
culture and we have to be engaged in
changing it Arthur Brooks is the CEO the
president of the American Enterprise
Institute which is one of the leading
think tanks in Washington DC a
center-right think tank and he's a good
friend and wonderful guy he has
befriended the Dalai Lama which I find
is a fairly unusual Odd Couple this
intellect conservative intellectual and
and his holiness and at one of their
last conference the Dalai Lama shows up
with all these big dog donors to the to
the to this prestigious think tank and
he goes Arthur says to the Dalai Lama it
didn't say what's the meaning of life
that would have been my first question
he he asks how do we change our part the
political climate in the Dalai Lama had
observations that I think are really
true he says the solution doesn't start
with institutions it starts with people
that if you think
about it in that way then we have a
responsibility to change who we are and
in politics that means that the first
impulse shouldn't be to demonize someone
that disagrees with you because that's
what's happening right now in Washington
DC in Washington DC particular maybe not
in all state capitols Republicans don't
even interact with Democrats anymore and
Democrats obviously don't interact with
Republicans it's very easy to demonize
someone if you don't even know who they
are now I have liberal friends and
hopefully liberals have conservative
friends in our real lives that's kind of
what we do we still interact with one
another in Washington we should have
that same attitude that just because
someone disagrees with you doesn't mean
that they're a bad person if you start
with that premise it's amazing how the
culture could change and hopefully the
next president nited states will make
this one of their higher priorities is
to change that climate and the second
thing he said that I considered to be
extraordinarily important this time
where toughness and strength is measured
by vulgarity and the volume of your
voice in American political life what he
said is that people need to be warm
hearted again that they they should have
a heart for people that the first
impulse is to have concern for somebody
rather than to you know to promote
yourself if we were warm hearted as a
people my guess is our political system
will look dramatically different in
politicians that would prey on people's
angst and they're fierce would not gain
the kind of support that appears at
least temporarily that they're gaining
in the United States today if we're
serious about restoring democracy which
I think and I hope you all consider to
be important priority for the world and
certainly for our own country for the
sake of my grandchildren and everybody's
grandchildren and children this is a
hugely important deal we have to be warm
hearted again thank you all very much